[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Adam shefer let me give
you the official introduction ESPN's
coverage leading into the Eagles bucks
includes NFL live Monday night countdown
from Tampa their coverage starts at 3
Eastern then at 8 Eastern it's Joe and
Troy Lisa sulter Laura rutage they will
have the game oh Payton and Eli on ESPN
2 super Wildcard Weekend ends on the
ESPN network Works shefy joining us on
the program what level of phone call
would it take for you to say Dan I have
to take
this uh probably a 214 area cod or 972
and I'd be out the door Dan yeah I think
that's probably Fair all right give me
the team you think will be next to hire
their head
coach you know that's a hard thing to do
then because we're in a cycle now where
the league has done its best to slow the
process down where you're not allowed to
do face-to-face interviews till after
the divisional Playoff round you have to
interview two minorities face Toof face
I believe the Chargers already have done
one with Leslie Frasier so if you're
going down the charger path with Jim
Harbaugh they may or may not be in
compliance now they may or may not have
met all the conditions but I do think
that Jim's going to be a little bit
deliberate here the Chargers have other
interviews that they want to get through
and New England was an aberration last
week in getting J Mayo done because that
was in place but none of these other
teams have a plan like that and they're
not rushing and the league rules are
designed to try to slow this down so
you're asking me to predict something a
week to 10 days from now when there are
so many variables that will change
between now and then so it's hard to do
help me understand Harbaugh's situation
that it feels like he's you're he's a
Michigan guy he won a national title but
he keeps coming back to the NFL does he
does he want the NFL for leverage or
does he want to go back to no that has
nothing to do so if he's offered a job
if he's offered the Chargers job what's
Jim Harbaugh
do it's not that simple because you're
saying to me if he's off for the charger
job I say to you okay I'm off for the
charger job is the front office going to
be set up the way I want is the coaching
staff going to be set up the way I want
are you going to implement a nutrition
system are you going to put in
infrastructure that I want and need that
you always haven't been willing to do so
the Chargers could say yes Jim we offer
you the job well that's great what about
everything else that comes along with it
because before I commit to making a jump
to the NFL I want everything to know
that everything is in place that I need
to succeed at the next level the way
that I've succeeded everywhere during my
coaching career we're not doing this the
way the Chargers have done this for as
long as anybody could remember if you
can change everything that I want and
everything that I need and you're
offering me the job I think he's taking
it
yes who else is going to be in play for
Harbaugh uh well I think Mark Davis has
toyed with the idea of whether or not to
pursue Jim Harbaugh I wouldn't be
shocked if Atlanta made a call to Jim
Harbaugh let's see if there's any other
jobs that's still open but I I do
think that for the time being the focus
should be on the Chargers I think this
is a match that is potentially waiting
to happen in the sense that I believe
they want him they're looking at other
veteran coaches as well they'll look at
Bill bich they'll look at Mike Vel but I
believe that Jim Harbaugh stands out to
the Chargers on that list and I believe
that that's an organization has played
for he coached in San Diego he loves
Justin Herbert it fits if they could
make it all work and with Jim there are
always a lot of questions about making
it all work right so even though I sound
like I'm saying that this is trending
the right way and on a path to happening
there still are a lot of Hoops and
obstacles that both sides have to get
through before they can make happen
but Dan Jim has all the leverage he
needs at Michigan he doesn't need any
more NFL lever has nothing to do with
this what would it take for Jerry Jones
to move on from Mike McCarthy in your
opinion well here's the issue I I go
back to what everybody said to me during
the course of the season and everybody
kept saying is Jerry is gonna judge Mike
McCarthy on how Dallas does in its last
game they kept saying that over and over
well we saw Dallas's last game of the
season yesterday and if he's judging him
on that game I think we all know how
this is going to go but I do not think
that Jerry Jones ever thought that he
would be confronted with the fact that
he would have to make a decision after
that game he went into that game
Thinking okay let's get ready to host
the divisional playoff game next weekend
against the Detroit Lions or whoever
else advances to come meet us and lo and
behold Green Bay wins the toss
takes the ball sticks it down as Dallas
throat and never ever ever waivers and
Dallas seemed to be playing from behind
all day because it was uh so this is all
new to Jerry Jerry's processing it
what's it gonna take he's going to
decide that Mike McCarthy wouldn't be
the guy that can get us to the next
level yeah we've won 12 straight games
three straight years we've done nothing
in the playoffs we've embarrassed
ourselves three straight years two
embarrassing losses to the 49ers one to
the Packers and he would have to decide
that there's somebody else that he
believes in and we are in a period where
there's never been never been this much
coaching Talent free for hire that he
would decide that there's somebody else
out there that would give this team a
better chance to advance in the
postseason how attractive is this for
bellich if that job would
open well I think the Cowboys in general
are just an attractive job for bill for
Mike Vel for whoever else would be in
consideration Dan Quinn you could say so
um they're America's team
they're they're the focus of the
football universe so often and they have
talent like they do have talent now they
have some big decisions to make a lot of
free agents too so that that roster is
definitely going to require some work
and retooling during the off season and
that was why this was such an important
year because you heard so many people
say say well this is Dallas's best
chance ever H well it lasted to about
Green Bay first possession before you
realize it wasn't Dallas's best chance
well we also have you know Jerry will he
relinquish a little bit of that power if
I'm bellich going in there yeah I don't
think I don't think that's about I don't
think that's it's about like Bill one
week ago in what was one of his final
press conferences with the reporters in
the New England area said hey I don't
have to have all the person
power I don't that's not what it's about
Bill first and foremost is a football
coach and you know his one of his
mentors made it work there in Dallas
with Jerry and there's no reason that
bill also couldn't make it work if
that's what both sides wanted to do Pete
Carrol gonna be a head coach again I
hope so but I wonder like it seems like
people are gravitating more towards Jim
Harbaugh Bill bich Ben Johnson Aaron
Glenn some of these other names out
there right now and we'll see whether or
not he gets the look that he should to
me P Carol and La Nob brainer Nob
brainer like brings the positive energy
that they want brings the relevancy that
they need like that would be to me a
tremendous hire and that's the other
thing so you may want Jim Harbaugh you
may start down this path and maybe what
he wants to do with that organization is
too much for you and you say you know
what let's just go with p do I think
they're going to do that no but does it
make sense to me yes yeah I agree with
you on that I could I could see that
that'd be a lot of fun uh Mike vel's
value is what where does he sort of fit
in well he's still one he's still one of
the best coaches in the game and again I
think you have to see some of these
dominoes start falling before you can
see where his value fits in other than I
think he's on the minds of people in
Atlanta Seattle he's had a great
relationship with the general manager
John Schneider there for quite some time
that wouldn't be a surprise to see him
be a candidate there but to actually
Place him into a spot that's hard to do
right now other than I could see him in
Seattle I could see him in Atlanta I
could see him at other places depending
on how their searches
go yeah it's fascinating time really is
that Dan it always is it always is okay
that's how I have a job you know that's
what this league does we go from the
playoffs to The Hires and Fir to free
agency to quarterbacks mie well will the
Bears keep Justin fields and who's
taking the quarterback and who's coming
up for the it's one soapbox drama after
another it's great for your show yeah
it's great people love it right you've
been in business for a long time and the
NFL reality show it just feels like just
gets larger and larger and larger and
more and more popular over time this is
the deadline to announce the to declare
for the draft but Caleb Williams hasn't
declared for the draft yep not yet I
would expect that he would today at some
point in time okay uh the Washington
Commander's job is kind of quiet like is
that a good
thing well what's quiet it's quiet
because there are other things that have
taken precedent over that like the
availability of all these huge name free
agent coaches but it's not quiet in the
coaching Community they did hire a
general manager on fra Adam Peters the
former assist general manager of the
49ers and Adam Peters with the help and
assistance of the former Vikings GM Rick
Spielman and the former Warriors
executive Bob Meyers and Josh Harris and
that ownership group like M Magic
Johnson they'll make a decision uh
they've got a whole host of candidates a
slew of them and I do believe that Ben
Johnson is is on that list now whether
they can get him or not we'll see
because there's going to be a lot of
people that want Ben Johnson as well
again just think about it
belich Harbaugh Pete Carroll Mike
Rabel established Proven Winners next
tier Ben Johnson Aaron Glenn Raheem
Morris like Brian there there's a lot of
guys out there right now that warrant
and deserve consideration and like I
said very rarely do you have the ability
for a team to be able to pick from a
coaching pool of candidates this deep
great to talk to you I know you're busy
have a great great afternoon thank you
Adam thank you Dan appreciate it nice to
see you that's Adam schfer ESPN senior
NFL Insider